hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today
and don't forget to hit the like button
it supports the channel a lot so today
let's look at leak code 121
best time to buy and sell a stock so if
you know a little about the stock market
the saying is usually buy low
and sell high so in this case
we're given an input array now each
value
represents the price of the of a stock
at a particular day and we we
are given one transaction meaning we can
buy
on one of these days and then sell on
another day
and we want a transaction that maximizes
our profit and then we want to return
that profit in this
case if we buy on day two when the price
is
one and sell day five when the price is
six
that's what's going to maximize the
profit for us so as always
i'm going to draw a picture and show you
that this problem is actually not too
bad
even the optimal solution so on day one
it was at price seven and then it went
down all the way to price one
the next day it went from price one all
the way up to price
five and we could just keep going with
this right so
next day went down and the next day it
went up
and the last day it went down again
so looking at the picture it's pretty
clear that
the max profit we can get is simply by
taking
the minimum here and the max
here and if we look at the actual values
for that
we see that this is one this
is six so the profit is gonna be
six minus one which is
five but notice how we there's actually
a greater
maximum than this one right like this is
six but this is
seven so why can't we just do this
because then we get seven minus one
which is six which is
even bigger than five well it turns out
we know that time
moves in one direction right we can't go
back in time to sell at this price
so how are we going to solve that
problem well there's a pretty common
programming technique two pointers so
we're gonna initialize
a left pointer on day one
and our right pointer on day two which
makes sense
right is gonna be to the right of left
and so we're going to see
what's the current profit right now from
here
to here well it's going down right
that's not good it's negative
and in this case left is going to be the
day that we buy
and write is gonna be the day that we
sell
so the first thing you're gonna notice
is it's down right it's negative
this is not good we don't want a
negative profit why would we
buy left when we can buy right right
is less than left why would i pay
seven when i could wait one day and pay
one
so that's basically how the algorithm
works since
our right value is less than left we're
gonna update our pointer
left so left is now gonna be
on day two and right is gonna be on
day three so now we see
that the right value is actually greater
than the left value
but what's the profit
the profit in this case is going to be 5
minus
1 which we know equals 4
which is so far our current max profit
so for the current max i'm going to put
a 4.
and in this case since our left pointer
is less than our right pointer
since we're buying low and selling high
that means we can leave
our left pointer over here and we only
have to update our right pointer
now let's compare our left and right so
we're buying here we're selling here
in that case the profit is going to be 3
minus 1 which is only
2. so if you take a look at our current
max it's 4 so we're not going to update
our max profit
and we notice that our left pointer
we're buying low and we're still
selling high it's not as high as this
but we still
don't need to update the left pointer
and so now
we get to the actual uh result case that
we already know about but
let's compute it so this is at six
this is at one so we found
a new max profit six minus one
is five so let's update our max
so our algorithm is gonna keep going
even though we can tell by the picture
that we did find the mac so it's gonna
end up checking this last case
which left we're buying one and we're
selling at i think this is
four so we know four minus one is three
not greater than five so our algorithm
is complete we
found our max profit of
five and if we wanna know the memory
and extra space we used we know we
didn't really use extra memory we used a
couple pointers but no array so
extra memory is 01 time is going to be
linear because this is a two pointer
solution
we're not doing any brute force stuff
this is going to be
big o of and we only have to scan
through the array
uh one time even though we have two
pointers
okay now let's code it up so we do have
a left and right pointer
left is going to be initialized to 0 and
right is going to be initialized to 1
just like in our picture we know left
is buying right
is selling we can initialize our max
profit
to zero as like the default case and
we're gonna
keep iterating through prices while our
right pointer
has not uh passed the end of prices
now we wanna check is this a profitable
transaction and how do we check that
well
if prices of left
is less than prices of right
now if this is profitable let's
calculate that profit
which is going to be
so this is just the math right price is
a right minus left
and now we can potentially update our
max profit but we don't know for sure so
we're going to check
the maximum of the current max profit
as well as the profit that we just
computed so whatever the max is is going
to be assigned
to the new max profit but it might
not be a profitable transaction which in
that case
we can update our left pointer
now regardless of the conditions we want
to
update our right pointer and so this is
obviously going to keep going
until our right pointer is out of bounds
in which case we've gone through
all of the values and we know that max p
has the result that we want to return so
i actually had a small
bug over here instead of incrementing
left by one
if the left price is not less than the
right price we don't just want to shift
our left pointer by one we want to shift
it
all the way to the right because we
found
a really low price we found the lowest
price
that we could pretty much we basically
want our left pointer to be
at the minimum and you can tell from
this picture
that if our left was here and our right
was over here
we don't just want to shift our left
pointer by one because then it's up here
we want the left pointer to be low right
we want to buy
low sell high so we would shift our left
pointer
all the way over here
so we'd cross this out put the left here
and then the right pointer would be over
here
and we can see that this would be a
super good profit for us
and now we can submit our solution and
it's
over 90 so we're in the clear we found a
very optimal solution for this problem
i hope it was helpful please like and
subscribe to support the channel
and i'll hopefully see you pretty soon